you are obviously here to promote the
release of Curb Your Enthusiasm season 9
that's not no I'm not you're not what do
you mean we're here to promote Curb Your
Enthusiasm the ninth season we got the
deep not yet it's okay show but no no
it's been done already that's in the
past that that's something that happened
already okay
you know everybody's asking me JB Smoove
what's next for you yeah nobody's
talking about season 9 occur be
enthusiastic well wait okay well what
what are you here to talk about a lot of
things on my mind now look none of these
things are copy written so please don't
steal my stuff Conan what are you
talking about do you have ideas for new
shows feet of ideas everyone's calling
me you gotta be prepared when people
call you for ideas you gotta have a lot
of ideas in your head one idea that's
really cool it's called repo man yeah
this is that show called repo man yeah
repo man I go and I try to get your old
girlfriend back from a new boyfriend
[Laughter]
I'll befriend this guy right here friend
a guy ever in the bottom around I'll be
friendly maybe in the auto parts line
like an auto parts store somewhere we
talk about cars but I've become
affirming him right before dinner
and I go over there mess things up a
little bit yeah for now take a bat and
go back to you so yeah yeah that's a
great I would watch that show repo man
go through it man what other shows you
got besides really anything else yeah of
course I got one call living under baby
pool oh let me get this straight
living under a baby pool yeah we're on
the baby pool what's that about what the
hell you think is about is about a dude
living under damn baby pool huh
he just drains it he just puts it over
his head and he just crouches here on
the lawn no he's under the baby pool
he's underneath inside the baby pool
laying inside it under it the reality
show okay that's awful that's a terrible
idea
okay any other ideas plenty of ideas
brother Oh
oh yeah one idea core gonna have to top
Oh living under a baby pool oh yes yes
we got ideas man I got one call let's
not make this about me
it's a late-night show comes on even
later than your show lately later than
this show oh come on my show and they
ask me questions see like Tom Hanks
comes on there
he's an interview a thousand times but
this time he comes on the show and he
asks me questions see yes another
question you've already heard a man yeah
good ideas yeah I got one idea called
carnival cops oh this is really cool
it's carnival cops yeah it's kind of
like like training day right it's one
cool suave detective like myself a cool
cop then there's one awkward kind of
goofy guy that's my sidekick you know
saying he's like man he's he's my
partner
you know you'll be good as like the
awkward goofy kind of goofy sidekick in
this show it's a really cool show yeah
and we ride around on unicycles
what are you doing here these are cops
cops that ride unicycles right unicycles
right and they patrolled the carnivals
make sure everything is cool like andis
stealing stealing cotton candy or funnel
cake and that kind of stuff
Robbie police that kind of stuff we'll
see a little preview of it you have a
clip of it right here no make a clip
you're gonna make it clip right now how
about me you come on what are we gonna
do come on you leave my part oh these
that's what these hats are for you he's
out in the commercial break are there
unicycles back there please say yes no
fake unicycles say it's real all right
come on man all right okay mr. awkward
come on all right so you're the you're
the you're the cop you're the cool
[Music]
all right yeah we're gonna watch these
folks around here man they gotta turn
the feet of feel cotton candy in and
funnel cake in you know I wouldn't know
about that I'm just a goofy nerd he's
moving over there Wow
oh look at that yeah yeah the guy just
took that a little stuffed animal from
that that little baby yep yeah
[Applause]
Oh sir
you